it's great to be joined today by Ben
winters who's author of the New York
Times bestseller
underground Airlines as well as the last
policeman trilogy
I just finished I think it's two or
three days ago been underground Airlines
and I know I have a couple of friends
that are reading it really really
enjoyed it let's first talk about the
concept here which is it's modern-day
United States technology mobile phones
internet etc but the civil war didn't
happen and slavery is still legal in
four states so first talk to us about
how you conceived of this universe for
the writing of the novel well there are
two things I mean we're the universe the
idea for the book I think came from my
own sort of shock and horror as I think
a lot of Americans share most with the
continuing string of police violence
sort of incidents in which African
Americans were being shot and killed and
this sort of this sort of and the
underlying inequality underneath that
and I guess it was a sense of how is
this possibly still happening and the
one the first one that really struck me
I think I did a lot of people was
Trayvon Martin which was in 2000 who was
murdered and so I think there was a lot
of thinking about well how was this
still happening happened to still be and
trying to pay attention to the public
conversation or a race I noticed or one
thing that really struck me was that the
idea of slavery was really never part of
the conversation It was as if people had
forgotten that our country began as a
slave state no not some people but a lot
of people and it seemed important to me
to be thinking about all the ways that
the institutions and attitudes that
began in the time of slavery are still
with us and are still sort of shadowing
contemporary society so I guess from
there it was a it was taking that
figurative idea of like in a way slavery
still with us and making it literal
slavery is still with us when you use
according to them puts together the
story arc did you and I've interviewed
different fiction authors who have very
very different answers to death to this
did you have more of a sense of sort of
some of the elements that you wanted to
be part of the sort of social message
were you more initially thinking of what
this
ARC would be and then you would fill in
the universe as it sort of made sense
that you start with an outline that you
just start writing chapter one I mean
what was your process definitely there
was an outline although the outline
quickly gets thrown away and then
revised and thrown away again the
revised there's a lot of when I come
back and forth I think for this book it
was really important to me that it
neither be a bunch of social messages
hitting you over the head you know it
couldn't just be a pamphlet it couldn't
just be here's my ideas here's what I
think is wrong with America because that
would be boring will be moralizing and
it wouldn't be a good read you know but
at the same time it was super important
to me that the book not just be a
thriller set in a high concept version
of America that the book that the moral
force of the book was always in was
always in place so I was kind of walking
that line the whole time saying how can
I make this book maximally interesting
maximally engrossing as a thriller as a
mystery novel well at the same time
using as a way to think about the world
to think to use this alternate version
of America as a way of thinking about
real America you know that was
interesting to me in the sense that
while as you read it there there's much
you can sort of deduce and and speculate
about what message you're trying to send
about America today but one of the most
interesting overarching ideas I came
away with and I don't know if this was
something deliberate or not that that
you wanted to have come people come away
with from reading the book is the idea
that we often think today in 2016 there
really is no other way that things could
be right now this is sort of the this is
the obvious way that history would have
progressed and in reading a lot of
historical nonfiction one of the main
points that I've come away with and your
book sort of strengthened that is that
the way things are now really happened
by chance and it could have just as
easily gone completely differently if
any number of small differences had
existed in history is that sort of a
deliberate impression you're trying to
give or did I come up with that sort of
on my own no I mean I think that's an
interesting takeaway from the book it
certainly wasn't like my first and
foremost idea because although this is a
work of speculative speculative fiction
I'm more using that genre as a way of
thinking about you know our contemporary
situate
but certainly it is so that is store
that are that could the contemporary
reality is always the result of these
contingencies of this like these
extremely happenstance you know terms of
a you know these these things that
happen that who knows what would have
happened if Lincoln really was
assassinated earlier or if he was never
assassinated like how how my
reconstruction had gone differently if
Lincoln had lived or you know World War
one was started by this sort of this
chance of this one political
assassination but then you think well
but these forces were gonna collide that
we're going to collide eventually anyway
really interesting people love to talk
about the civil war and people say well
you know it was really a waste of life
because slavery eventually would have
withered away anyway and that I think is
one thing I'm definitely poking act with
this novel and trying to think about the
ways that in fact slavery might very
well continue maybe if not until the
present day certainly for a lot longer
than people like to thank because the
forces that were sort of aligned behind
it so yeah it's it's an interesting
thing to think about all the ways that
we get to where we are I want to talk to
you about some of the reactions that you
may or may not have received to the book
and the sort of context for these
questions is that when I've sometimes
done commentaries about anything from
black lives matter to other other topics
of sort of national news worthiness
sometimes my identity has been used as a
way to sort of dismiss my perspective
right how could I possibly be in a
position to comment on issue a B or C
because of my perceived white male
identity the main character in your book
is black and of course we're talking
here about an alternate history that
that includes slavery for much longer
than we had it in the real world have
you received any critiques because you
as a white guy someone felt you were not
the right person to be writing this
story oh sure oh yeah certainly well
there are two sort of facets of it and
one was the criticism that I was pushed
back that I had been expecting and
anticipated was exactly that well what
sort of is it appropriate for I as a
white person to be writing this book but
then also there was the issue of I'm so
related issue of there are
black authors plenty of black authors
out there many of them have written
about slavery and often in a sort of
science fiction context as I'm doing
here and like Octavia Butler and Walter
Mosley have a book and I think there was
a questioning of why is in my book
getting the sort of level of attention
is that because I'm white and you know I
I tried to and I continued to try to
like look at those criticisms honestly
and respectfully and answer them as
forthrightly as I can because I think
that is the only appropriate role for a
white person who is trying to engage
with race it's tough because I think
that as white people we have not only a
responsibility but a a high
responsibility a high level of
responsibility to think about racial
discrimination and inequality and to
engage with it which which to my mind
means reckoning with the history of
slavery and though I obviously did not
hold slaves and my ancestors didn't
happen to be here in hold slaves by the
fact that I am white I have enjoyed
consciously or not privileged throughout
my life in this country the privilege
that comes from the discrimination
against other people so that puts me in
a position where it is beholden upon me
to engage with these issues and to think
about them and to UM to struggle for
racial equality and that may put me in a
position when people say who do you
think you are why are you inserting
yourself in this conversation and you
know my answer to that is this is our
conversation to have not us as white
people but us as Americans black and
white and I think um we have to be able
to to all engage with it so that's as
far as sort of your identity and that's
interesting what about as far as the
concept of the story and the way in
which you've chosen to say if history
had gone differently have you heard from
anybody who says I sort of find the idea
the concept the universe you've created
to be either offensive or insensitive in
some way no I mean I'm sure there are
people who have found it to be sort of
shocking and upsetting but I really I
think that because unfortunately the
universe I portray in the book is in so
many ways a tragically similar to the
universe that we actually inhabit um I
don't think the people were like how
could he possibly have thought of this I
think unfortunately most people are like
god that's really uncomfortable because
like the hero my book is pulled over and
body search because he's black well
guess what that happens all the time
you know my hero in the book has to
carry his papers with him because he's
going to his papers are going to be
checked I mean like we have people now
struggling to make sure that black
people can vote because they don't have
the proper kind of ID like we live in a
world that is not nearly far enough away
from the world of the America that I
described in this novel and I think that
is what is unsettling to people not some
idea of what does this guy think does he
want there to be slavery I don't think
you would have to really bend over
backwards to think that I is the author
I'm arguing that this would be a better
you know reality I think it's fairly
self-evidently a critique or a way of
thinking about where we actually are you
know I will remind you we've been
speaking about the New York Times
bestseller underground Airlines we've
been speaking with the book's author Ben
winters who is also author of the last
policeman trilogy Ben thanks so much for
talking to me really enjoyed the book
and it's been a pleasure speaking with
you pleasure thanks a lot for your time